well hello camera and YouTube
I'm Greg I'm John I'm Perry Perry
Nemiroff from the twitter and instagram
@ p Nemiroff and she's also on Collider
videos you can catch her on many
Collider videos and the shmell damn I
feel like people point out that I have a
deep voice I'm trying to talk in a
higher voice you also express all of my
like social media information but
clearest in this there's been a couple
people for the past like two months
requesting that I check out the trailer
for before I fall in line is your
question several times
spelled it wrong in this screenshot I
got right now I fail but before I fail
before unveil is the youtube poop
version yeah
so people have been requesting this and
it's been a few months it's trick amount
I thought let's make this special event
and get three people for the video you
know Tice a few more people to watch the
video now that's a net real Wow showing
it's kind of like a like a pyramid
scheme laid out and we watch you're
wearing more people why are you three
people for the Power Rangers that's not
a big deal before I fall it is I like
the star of it is only doing China I
want you know what she was in yeah the
star of gardens of galaxies no how do I
know I really want everybody wanted both
of me
but I want good things for her and I
don't think she's had like a about
celebrities I don't want your things
well I'm good actress it just hasn't
picked movies that are of not that well
they're fabulous several people are
demanding we watch this
it must look good it's a time loop is
Mattoon even so I don't hear good thing
about oh you did it tomorrow
but for some of us very something today
hey sexy yes yes you love I like that
moving yeah you guys before you oh my
god what you're doing high school man
what are you doing what happened last
night please
ah like Groundhog Day
hey mom are you okay it wasn't a dream
it really happened again
[Music]
it's not so well
okay well this movies already out it
isn't it
oh man I know this mm-hmm this reaction
still going up request came in today how
about this let's make this a game okay
let's give our opinions or what we think
then we're gonna go rotten tomatoes do
it today yeah I like am this is this
based on a book I feel like it's based
on a young adult I'm this is based on it
out it was well wait a great while and
again like the singing type of climate
thinking that deal with evolutionary log
escape this is definitely not for me
despite the fact that I like the people
that are in it
oh my god I like time-loop stories
Groundhog Day edges tomorrow only to it
there you go those are different types
of timeless but yeah I know I know you
see they've been lined up putting that
in that category to be shocked
I would have to go with a rail who would
want to be interested in watching this
movie because this seems very much
targeted towards a very specific young
teen they're alive today yeah I feel
we're going like with John go watch this
move here right now I would go I would
go with you really I didn't think you
could do that you should go and I should
follow you with a hidden camera
just like capture how many are guilty
bad - Leon was crying yeah so men fire
decisions is taking throughout the story
she's really growing so one night can
you get a la le I mean anastasiya I like
to be optimistic with trailers as much
out of can be because I go it's just a
trailer it's just a trailer it could be
good critics might like it audience
might like it chose to be very
misleading because you know it's like
the marketing department thinking how do
i market this but from what we're
getting really cheesy
it looks really intense it looks like it
really wants to be invent corny like :
not in like the intentional way looks
like everyone like a movie but it's so
serious about high school problems but
it does take it so very seriously and
that's like the recipe for unintentional
yeah oh I like that we keep taking to
our ladies things and just stripping
away the fantasy one level at a time so
now this is shot like a fantasy to see
how I guess reminds me of what was the
that Chloe Moretz once it was like super
ye and oh this way yeah oh not this way
there was another one - Gary not that
one I bear sherry but this way was that
Chloe Moretz died
oh oh it's with the chill oh yeah yeah
oh oh the title kind of like person um
I'd say wow I can't believe I remember
that what I felt in my way my dad in
this I wasn't I really didn't make it my
back okay but okay I mean I thought it's
been so cheesy when she died like four
times or something but she's like I need
to make a choice about not dying the
time I thought maybe I can bring hot
lunch but no sniffing it should make the
search the second time if you see it
coming to not do it the power of the
sound but that's what they want what do
you guys think is together on Tomatoes I
haven't checked the Rotten Tomatoes they
come out I had no idea what a guy no
it's not good
because a couple of people that I
trusted seeing as how he didn't like it
74 percent 74 yeah audience what I said
I would get 47% with an audience score
of 70% I'm gonna go 20 to 50
I'm gonna go 27 whoa 45 I'm Tom aha
they've heard it about all right let's
find this out I've never guessed the
audience or to nor mine but find this
out I know my scores are normally pretty
high surprisingly high at least it ended
before I fall 68%
oh what the audience I was close Wow
familiar ingredients are enlivened by a
fresh young adult perspective and a
strong performance from emerging stars
of go away that is nutty well done 82
review 68 that Wow the majority like
I've seen it never viewed it wasn't just
like oh I don't like this movie oh they
gave it a piss-poor review thought it
was the worst thing ever
I'm shocked that is shocking yeah Jordan
people like it maybe the audience liked
it out of it stuck with my first guest
what would your pretty happy yeah we
should have betted something there was
not me I'm fond of stake to reputation
yeah yeah sounds like a great idea that
you can have on our it well yes maybe we
have to take time to maybe consider
watching turtle it'll be enough even the
rod to beta the rod tomatoes score makes
me a little more intrigue for sure
actually I guess I don't it's not like
incredibly high but I can play like you
to rave about the Zoey Rd actress yeah
cheese would taste great
you seen Vampire Academy I have yeah
that's what is so low reviews yeah it's
fun it was fun yeah it was it got an
unfair release an unfair release and
press push Vampire Academy was the first
video that started booming this channel
ain't kidding I remember I did a
reaction to it and I was by myself I
mean I just shot off my computer
and it's only a bunch of young girl
hearted tweeting out my reactions I
really like the trailer yeah I couldn't
pinpoint where she is from
that's right an ER that is it and she
just have that movie with my James
Franco and Bryan Cranston why him Oh
Ellis her oh there's about Trumbo oh if
someone wants to watch this and they end
up going alright I'll go with them
that's my massage decision on this if
you're near the channel
scrap it the real real nuts or like
anybody anybody someone goes right when
we definitely you ever any allegories up
the answers if you sent a dick six
no no that's when I that's when I did
screenshot and show my friends look at
those guys you know 2001 of dicks on
great jobs reasons to charity on Twitter
and Instagram he local media manager of
the real rejects EA p never off on
Twitter Instagram she is one of the main
phases of Collider videos that's an
overstatement no it's not I ride every
once in a lottery I'll be Oscars you're
driving I don't have to look lovely
oh you look absolutely tiny a lot of
Oscar movies I don't know you look
absolutely beautiful in that video
David's all my life is zucchini and you
look good
is that oh that was it a lot actually I
like Spanish do I know nothing about it